hi it's easy to feel like motion design
is Out Of Reach if you're not an
illustrator or you don't know how to
draw but the truth is you can still
create amazing motion design even
without those skills I know this because
I've been there I used to think that
because I couldn't draw I couldn't
design Motion Graphics but I quickly
learned that motion design is about so
much more than just drawing skills it's
about using typography shapes and
composition to bring your ideas to life
so if you're interested in motion design
don't let a lack of drawing skills hold
you back there are plenty of design
possibilities for you to explore and
with a little bit of creativity you can
create stunning motion design that will
make a big impact